when working on machine learning
problems it's easy to be laser focused
on the model training
but the data is really where it all
starts so today we'll cover the basics
of storing data for model training and
see how to access training data from the
vertex ai workbench notebook that we
created in the last episode i'm nikita
and this is prototype to production
where we go from notebook code to a
deployed model in the cloud
[Music]
before we get into the data let's take a
look at the image classification example
that we'll use throughout the series but
note that if you have a different data
type or prediction task a lot of what we
cover in this series will still be
applicable to your use case
so here's a collab notebook that trains
an image classification model on the
flower photos data set
the data set is in a folder called
flower photos which gets loaded directly
into the runtime when i execute this
cell
the flower photos directory contains
five subdirectories one for each flower
type in our data set
these directories contain jpegs of the
corresponding flowers
the next cells in our notebook create
our training and validation data sets
define the model using tensorflow and
keras then train and save the model
our goal is to take all of this code and
run it on google cloud's manage machine
learning platform vertex ai
but if you want to train models on
vertex ai first you need to get your
data into the cloud if you've been
working in a different environment like
colab or locally etc you can upload any
code artifacts you need to your vertex
ci workbench managed notebook and you
can even integrate with github
in the future you can do all of your
development right here in workbench but
for now let's download this collab
notebook as a ipynb file and then upload
it to workbench
if you're using something like tf
datasets or downloading data off the
internet you can do that directly in the
notebook just like you would in collab
or in a local environment
so for example if i execute these cells
here it'll download the flowers dataset
directly to the instance and we can
access them that way
or if your dataset is small enough you
could even load it directly into the
instance by clicking the upload button
right here
now that we've downloaded the data we
can run through the rest of the cells in
this notebook
and there you go you're training a model
on google cloud
now this might work for experimentation
but for something more production ready
you probably want to store the data
within your project in a centralized
location instead of directly on the
machine where your notebook is running
and that's what cloud storage is there
for cloud storage is google cloud's
object storage
meaning you can store images csv files
text files saved model artifacts just
about anything
cloud storage has the concept of a
bucket which is what holds your data
everything you store in cloud storage
must be contained in a bucket and within
a bucket you can create folders to
organize your data
each file in cloud storage has a path
just like a file on your local file
system except that cloud storage paths
always start with gs colon slash so here
in the ui i've created a bucket called
prototype to production bucket
you can upload files and create folders
in the ui
or you can upload files programmatically
with the gsutil tool
this tool is installed automatically in
workbench but if you want to use it to
locally upload data from your machine to
cloud storage then you'll need to
install the cloud sdk and instructions
on how to do that are linked below
so let's use the gsutil command to copy
the data we downloaded in our workbench
notebook to our cloud storage bucket
we add the exclamation point to execute
this as a shell command then type gsutil
cp to copy
we add the dash r because we want to
copy the entire directory and dash m to
perform a multi-processing copy which
will just speed things up
once the data is copied we can check out
the bucket in the ui
we can go into one of these folders and
see all of the images
when you have data in cloud storage you
can often still access it using the same
methods you would before
you'll just need to pass in the cloud
storage path also known as a uri instead
of a local path
so for example if you're familiar with
using tf records you might use the tf
data tf record data set class to create
your data set you can pass in a cloud
storage uri
and read the data just like you would if
the data was stored locally
and you could even do the same thing
with image dataset from directory which
is the function we're using in this
sample in this episode we saw how to
download data directly to our vertex ai
workbench instances for experimentation
and how to create and upload data to
cloud storage buckets via the ui and the
gsutil tool
vertex ai workbench and cloud storage
are building blocks
that will be a core part of our machine
learning journey on google cloud in the
next episode we'll learn about running
custom training jobs on vertex ai's
managed training service and how to kick
off a training job from a workbench
instance don't forget to like and
subscribe for more great content and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you